ice skating may be a winter sport but
this summer it's a popular option for
those wanting to escape soaring
temperatures outside parts of China are
experiencing the most severe heat wave
in recent history the Northwestern
province of xinjiang reached a record
high of 52.2 degrees Celsius on Sunday
it's raising concerns over agricultural
output cotton crops are among those
affected in the Northeast hundreds of
pigs died after a power outage disrupted
a Farm's ventilation system
analysts say the climate emergency is
more evident than ever before
in China most people agree on the
climate change issue but what's a shame
is many don't see the connection between
climate and their own behaviors the
drought though affects hydropower
generation so when electricity is cut
this impacts Industries and the people
air conditioners cannot even be used so
this is giving people a very real
first-hand experience in Beijing U.S
climate Envoy John Kerry met Premier Lee
Chung and top Diplomat Wong Yi Kerry
warned the extreme weather could worsen
incoming weeks
China and the United States are the two
most powerful economies in the world
we also have to admit the two largest
emitters of greenhouse gases
and so the imperative of our two
countries coming together and working
and showing the rest of the world how we
can cooperate and begin to address this
with the urgency it requires
it is incredible
both sides say climate cooperation could
provide a fresh start for their troubled
relationship but disagreements over
climate financing and coal consumption
Remain the staging Park is usually
crowded at this time of year but there's
no one in size people in northern China
are doing whatever they can to try to
avoid the sweltering heat while those in
the South are being inundated by heavy
rains in the city of fujo rescue
operations are underway after a typhoon
struck on Monday a red alert for flash
flooding has been issued in guangxi
province
Chinese authorities say extreme weather
will continue for another 10 days public
air-conditioned areas have been set up
in some cities and others are using
whatever means necessary to stay cool
Katrina Beijing